hi everyone here on the freecodecam
channel today
in this course i will be showing you how
you can build the tools that everyday
startups need in a matter of hours by
learning how to build using the low code
approach
my name is kubo and i am a software
developer course creator as well as your
instructor for this action-packed
low-code course in which you will learn
how to build a customer support
dashboard thanks to local solutions and
apis
for those of you who are new to low code
it is an approach in which a developer
can choose to use a platform that
already provides certain ui components
for our disposal as well as
pre-configured ways to plug in apis
this is a great time saver when it comes
to spinning up complex apps fast
low-code solutions are not to be
confused with no-code solutions in which
no coding knowledge is required
this is why a prerequisite for this
course is to have a basic understanding
of javascript and http request methods
in order to fully grasp its contents
however if you do not have any of that
please do not let that stop you from
following along anyway as i will be
taking you through everything step by
step
okay
wonderful so let's get to it by the end
of this course you will have a support
dashboard where you can modify customer
details browse order history refund
active orders and manually add orders if
you need using the appsmith platform and
the google sheet api you will also be
able to cancel and refund orders thanks
to the stripe api this course is made
possible from a grant from appsmith app
smith is an open source low code
framework the community edition is
feature-rich and completely free you can
self-host it or use their cloud version
and it's a great way to get started with
low-code development
okay so let's get to it let's get to
building our first app
so first things first i'm just going to
start off on the appsmith dashboard as
you can see this is my organization
called the anius apps and you can see
some previous apps that i have made
so all we're going to do once you get to
this position after signing up is go
ahead and click
new
okay so we are creating essentially a
new app i'm going to start off with
building from scratch
so let's go ahead and click this one and
you should see a blank canvas generate
for you while we are here i'm actually
going to rename my page so it's very
obvious for future projects and just for
organizational purposes
so let's go ahead and call this
zip
food
delivery as this is the app that we are
going to make it's going to be an order
dashboard so i've just called it zip
food delivery just like so and let's get
going
now i want you to first off think about
how you want to store your database
for this tutorial we're going to go
super simple and just use a google sheet
database
so if you haven't already signed up to
google please go ahead so that you can
access their google drive and in turn
create a google sheet
just like
so
so on my google sheet which i will be
linking in the description so please
feel free to go ahead and clone it if
you wish it will be open for use so just
go ahead and do that like so
so in this data let's talk it through a
little bit so this is our customer
database on the first tab we have the
orders and the orders will simply
consist of an order number followed by
the date that that order was made the
delivery address the total amount spent
in a currency value the status of it and
a stripe purchase id which we will be
going into later you will have to
replace these these are just some
template ones for this tutorial and then
we have the customer id of the customer
that ordered it so this brings me along
nicely to the second tab where you will
be able to see each customer by their id
so danny is customer id number one
we've got the first name the last name
the email address associated with that
user what date they joined if they sign
up for the newsletter and a random image
that we have assigned them okay so this
is just hosted online if you visit this
url you will see the image
and a phone number and same for the id
2.
next up i'm actually going to go to the
product catalog so here is just a
database of all the products that we
have in our store at the moment it's not
many we only have four items but again
this is just for tutorial purposes each
item has an id and an image which is
once again hosted on the internet so if
we visit this directly it will just show
us the image like so so make sure that
you can see this like this
okay
and
great one thing to note of course this
is hosted by someone else so if they
take this down we will no longer be able
to see the image so that is just
something to keep in mind
okay and finally we have the products
tab now this products tab is essentially
a better view on what is associated with
each order number so as you can see this
order number here
we will be able to see that this order
number consists of one birthday cake and
five lollipops okay
so
that is important as well that is how we
read this data once you feel comfortable
with what you're seeing here it will be
time to move on to start using this data
to start building out our
order dashboard so that it displays all
this information but also allows us to
add information to this database from
the dashboard itself
okay
we're going to add data we're going to
be able to
edit data as well so let's get to it i'm
excited let's go back to appsmith
so the first thing i'm going to do is
actually just hook up this database so
we can do so really easily i'm just
going to go to data sources over here
and i'm just going to pick google sheets
and we want to be able to read and write
as we will be adding data to the
spreadsheet so make sure that that is
connected and save and authorized
so now we'll just have to log in to our
google
drive so that appsmith can continue to
talk to it and has access to it so just
make those steps and
wonderful
so let's go ahead and perhaps change
what this is called i'm going to call
this
order
database just like so
and wonderful
so now let's go ahead and create a new
api so this is where we're going to tell
our platform that we want to get the
data okay from this spreadsheet so this
is simple all i'm going to do let's
perhaps rename this as well i'm going to
call this
get orders or fetch
fetch
orders okay as that is the first thing
we're going to fetch we're going to
fetch everything from this tab right
here
so just make sure that this says fetch
sheet rows
and then the sheet name for our
spreadsheet well it's going to be
orders so make sure to spell it exactly
as you see there so i'm just going to go
ahead and type orders like
so
and table heading row index we do have a
heading so i'm going to leave that as it
is
one
query format now the query format we're
going to query the rows that is correct
because we're going to be looking by the
rows
make sure that the spreadsheet url is
the one from yours right here so i'm
literally just going to take all of this
and just paste it in here like so and
then just simply
run
this
like so
so here is the data that is coming back
to us
this is looking
wonderful
now we have hard coded this is us 10 for
the moment but we can change this
dynamically but first let's get this
data into a table first
so all i'm going to do is go back to my
zip food delivery app
and then under widgets i'm just going to
click plus and then i'm going to select
the table widget
so let's go ahead and find that now here
is the table widget and i'm just simply
going to drop it like so
okay so here is my table the next thing
i want to do is actually get the data
necessary to populate this table
and to do this so let's just get rid of
that i'm going to use the
fetch
orders data data
just
like that
so there we go that is super simple
that's all i've done and now we can see
all our orders showing up here but just
our orders okay not any of the other
pages
okay
so
this is looking good i'm actually just
going to rename this to be
the order
table just to make things more readable
and things a little bit more organized
okay
so that is our order table
great
maybe let's make this orders table to be
a bit more precise
so we have our table however let's maybe
do some styling first so all i'm going
to do is just make this look a little
bit prettier before carrying on
so to do this i'm actually going to i
think grab a container so let's grab a
container
and i'm going to just work this whole
table in my container
so all these widgets they're also your
disposal and they essentially just make
you know app creation a lot more easier
if i was developing this from scratch it
would of course take me much longer to
create you know the container the table
and so on so this is one of the main
benefits of low code solutions we can
simply drag and drop things as we please
in making our app
so there we go and i'm just going to
drag this a little bit lower
just like so so that we could add a
title and a way for us to essentially
add more data to our table by creating a
pop-up modal
so the first thing i'm going to do is
just search for
the text
and just drag it in here oops
so there we go
now the text well the label for this is
going to say orders just so it's super
clear what this table is about we can
also use emojis if we want so i'm just
going to go ahead and grab an emoji
just whack it in like so
okay and then we can also choose to
change the color i want this to be a
title so i'm going to go ahead and
choose heading one for this so it's a
little bit larger but there is some
pre-configured text styles but again if
we want we can really take this uh that
next further step and really personalize
it to give it whatever colors we wish
okay
so there we go that is how you use the
text
now the next thing i want to do is just
create a button so that it shows a
pop-up model so again this is super easy
i'm just going to drag and drop an icon
button
i'm going to drag it in there
we can of course you know space this out
a little bit better if we wish
center that so now we have a way to add
a modal we can of course also style this
button let's actually call this
button and all i'm going to do to start
it up
is perhaps let's just change the color
of it so i'm just going to go with this
dark gray
and what else can we do we can change
the border radius to make it look like
this
and of course now we need to get an
event so on click
of this widget i need something to
happen
and what i want to happen is i want to
open the modal so i'm just going to go
ahead and write that show mojo and then
we need to essentially create a modal so
let's go back to our widgets one more
time
and i'm just going to find the modal
so here is my modal i'm just going to
drag it in here
okay and let's call this at modal
and let's not animate the loading let's
keep that one off scroll contact true so
we can scroll everything in here quit
dismiss also true and there's no action
for this at the moment
okay so now let's hook it up so on click
of this i want to show the modal
so open modal
and then select the modal add modal okay
so i've just selected the modal that
i've just created which we call admodal
which means that now if i click this my
modal will show up
great
so let's go ahead and add everything
that we need in here i'm just gonna say
add new
order
manually
just like so
okay and let's maybe spread this out a
little bit and just center it so it's in
the center
and let's also we can change the color
of these buttons so i'm just going to go
ahead and do that now i'm going to
choose this kind of color for this
and the clothes again i'm just going to
change it from being green
to this dark grayish color
okay wonderful for now i'm just going to
leave this as it is we will go back to
that later i want to carry on building
out our main dashboard first so another
thing i'm going to do is just quickly
add a header to this so once again i'm
going to get the container widget and
i'm just going to drag it up here
and then make it a little bit smaller
so that is looking good and now i'm just
going to drag my first container down
here a little bit again
so
there we go and then just make this one
maybe a little bit bigger so that we can
fit some more stuff in here like so
uh great and let's change the color of
this so what color do i want to make
this i think this blue would be quite
nice let's just go ahead and keep it as
that and once again i'm going to add
some text
so let's find our text widget
here is our text widget i'm just going
to drag this in here again let's change
the text color to be white
and then i want this to be an h1 heading
just like so and i'm going to call this
zip food delivery so just in here
zip
food
delivery okay and then we can change
this to title if we wish
so here's our title and once again just
going to add an emoji
and then i'm just going to add the emoji
like
so and i'm just going to add a sub
title now and the subtitle so once again
here's the label i'm going to say your
custom
dashboard to view
add
and delete
orders
let's make the text of this white and
i'm happy with it being a paragraph
so the paragraph default styling
and great
our header is looking good
so we have our header we have our orders
in a table we're gonna have a way for us
to add new orders manually
i'm also gonna go ahead and add a
refresh button to do this i'm actually
gonna grab the
icon button again but this time i'm
going to choose a different icon and
this icon is going to be the refresh
icon that looks like this
okay
so
wonderful and i'm actually going to make
the background white
to make it look like
this
so i'm really happy with this and we can
actually add an event to this already so
on the click of this refresh i actually
want to execute a query and it's a query
we've already written which is to fetch
the orders again okay so i'm going to
fetch the orders i'm going to rerun that
just like so
okay great and that is it so now if i
click this button i will essentially
refetch the data from our database if we
ever need to
wonderful
so we have that so far the next thing i
want to do is just display
our customer
okay the customer of our order if i
highlight one of the lines i want to
show me exactly who order it i want to
see their name i want to see their email
i want to see their phone number and
maybe a little picture of them too as we
do have that data available to us
so that is the next step once again i'm
just going to grab the container
just like so and just make that a little
bit smaller and in here i'm just going
to grab the text
and this is essentially going to show
the name of our customer
so we can even give it customer
name
just like so and then let's make this
maybe a little bit larger let's make
this i'm going to give it an h1
tag as well
the next thing we're going to do is just
show their email address so i'm actually
going to call this
email
address just give it a label so
everything is a lot more readable and a
lot easier for us to do let's maybe
change the color of this to be like blue
or something and then we're also going
to have the phone number so
name email phone number i'm going to
change this for readability to be
phone number
and
wonderful
and we also want to have that image
right so i'm just going to move this
over a little bit actually for now
and i can choose to have an image
so once again let's go back to the
widgets
and i am just going to find
the image widget
it's going to drag that in here
and this essentially is going to show me
the image of the customer when we pick
them out
okay
so again i'm just going to rename this
readability
customer
profile
wonderful so let's do it let's link it
all up
so to do this we're actually going to
have to make another query
so
let's go ahead and do that now so just
under queries i'm going to select this
and and we are going to
use the
order database we're going to make a new
order database query this one is going
to be fetch
user
and once again we're going to fetch the
sheet row we're going to get the url for
our spreadsheet so i'm just going to
paste that in here like so the sheet
name well the sheet name for this is
actually going to be the
customers okay because we want to get
this information right here so i'm just
going to make sure to spell exactly the
same way so customers and then let's
leave these blank we can increase the
row limit if we
wish
so i'm just going to put 20 for now and
then let's click run
okay
so there we go we're getting all our
customers and now we can use this fetch
user
query in order to fetch our users to
populate our app
so let's go back to here
now
what i'm going to do
is so instead of this default image
i'm going to once again get our two
curly braces and use the fetch
user
query so it's exactly exactly the same
as this one right here that fetches all
of our users i'm gonna go into the data
for now i'm just gonna put in the first
user and i'm going to get there
image
so let's go ahead and do that
making sure just for image with a
capital i
and great
so there we have our customer profile
however what i want to do is use
whatever
row i'm in to show the customer
profile
okay
so i'm going to show you how to do that
next
so all i'm going to do is go back to
fetch user and make sure to fetch just
the one user that is selected so to do
this i'm going to look for the user by
the id and the value is going to be
we're going to go into the orders table
how do we call it we call it orders
table so make sure to call it exactly
the same
okay because it's the name that we gave
our table widget
and i'm just going to choose selected
row
and i'm going to
search for the customer
id oops making sure to spell id with a
capital i
and making sure the operator is equal
equal so id equals customer id and click
run
so now let's go back to our zip through
delivery and talk it through again so we
are going into the orders table the
widget called orders table and the
selected row we are getting the customer
id
okay
and all it means that in here i am
looking
for the id with a column name
for our customers
equals
the customer id on our table
now to actually make this run every time
we click on one of these we're going to
have to run the
that user query so all i'm going to do
is go back in here and on the row
selected
so on row selected we'll have an action
i'm going to execute the query fetch
user okay so that's all we're going to
do we're going to fetch the user and
run it
okay
so there we go we can also have more
events on here so on page change we can
also rerun the fetch orders query just
to make sure that our fetch orders are
always the freshest it can be
so there we go so now let's check it out
i'm going to click on this one
and
here we have delphi and then if i click
on this one we have the user associated
with this next order
so that is all working good let's apply
the same logic to the email address
so all i'm going to do here is go into
the fetch
user query and just get the first row of
data okay and i'm gonna get the email
because after we click one of these
we're only gonna return
one customer which is why we could just
put a zero here we are literally just
going into the first oops these should
be curly braces the first
uh item in our returned array
okay
so there we go what's not what's going
on here oops
we need two curly braces at the end so
that is the syntax
for whenever you need to get data from
one of these
or
from a query
wonderful
[Music]
and last one you know what to do the
last one we want to get is the phone
number so once again here's the syntax
we're going to get up our curly braces
we're going to go into the fetch
user query which at the moment is
returning just one
object in an array if we click on any
one of these so we're going to go into
that object into the first object and
we're going to get the
phone number so i'm just going to double
check
how it's written here it's written phone
so that's what we're going to get we're
going to get the
phone
and
wonderful
okay
so this is looking good just to recap
once again to get this working it is
important to write another query so the
fetch user query we'll look into our
table it will look into the sheet of
customers so that's what i'm saying i'm
saying look in the sheet of customers
and then also look
okay
look at the id of the customer which is
one look at that and then match it with
the orders table selected row customer
id so essentially go into here look at
the orders table and look at the
selected row
custom id
and just return back the customer based
on that okay and then to get it shown
here we're just going to go into the
fetch user query and get the first item
returned in our array which should be
the user
so hopefully that now makes sense
hopefully us going over that again has
given you a better understanding of how
all of this works together
now that we have that let's carry on
so this is actually great because we're
going to use the exact same technique we
did to fetch the user to fetch a
specific
product or specific order so this is
great for repetition let's do it again
so the first thing i'm going to do is
just use a container
so let's make a new container not an
existing container i'm going to drag it
in here and this is going to display our
order information
so once again i'm just going to style it
out a little bit first i'm going to grab
some text
and let's call this order information
and then i'm just going to display the
order that we have here for now i'm just
going to leave it blank let's also make
this an h1 heading just like so just to
make it really big
and then let's perhaps also name this
something so we can call this
order
info so it's easier for us to pick out
so we've got our order information here
i'm just going to move this around a
little bit just to make it look a little
bit neater
and now what do we need well i'm going
to actually show the charge id
so let's go ahead and just put
charge
and once again i'm just going to put in
my charge id after this
from stripe so let's call this charge
info
so we're going to have our charge id
here and the next thing we're also going
to have so i can actually also just copy
and duplicate stuff like this
let's call this the address
info and this is going to obviously have
my address
once again i will leave that blank
because we're just you know getting the
basics ready for us to carry on and then
we're also going to have the status
the status of our order so let's put
status
info
and then perhaps let's also have the
order date
so i'm just actually going to drag that
over here and let's just put
date
and have this as date
info
wonderful
so there we have that and i'm just also
going to show our products that are
associated with this order so products
let's call this
product
title if you ever need to pick it out
that was what it is called
and in here i'm just going to show
perhaps an image
of our product so once again i'm just
going to drag this in here
for now even though we will need to map
stuff out
and then we're also going to have the
total amount so i'm just going to drag
this here
and amount
info and i'm just going to give this a
label
total
amount
okay
so this is looking good and the one last
thing we're going to do is actually add
a refund button so that we can refund
the order through the strike api if we
need
so let's get our button
just drag it here
and let's just call this
refund
and then let's make the button
maybe this blue color
we can also give it a border radius just
to soften it up a
little bit
so great
so now let's go back and we're going to
have to make a
another query you guessed it so in here
we're going to click here and we're
going to use a new order database query
so we're going to use our order database
in order to make a new query this time
however we're going to fetch the
products so let's do fetch
products just like so making sure to use
this url to this spreadsheet
and then this time the sheet i'm gonna
get is products
so let's go ahead and just put products
here
and click
run
okay so it's getting all the products
and we already know that we need to look
in here and we're going to look for the
order id this time so we're going to
grab this to make sure it's spot exactly
the same way we're going to look at our
table in here and get the order id and
make sure it is matched so let's just
whack that in here it's matched so we're
going to use the double equals sign so
this actually these two equals means
that it doesn't matter if we're
comparing a number to a string
uh that will be equal it doesn't look at
the type
okay so that is just something you
should know as well and we're gonna look
for
the order id in our table so what do we
call our table we called it orders table
i'm going to look at the selected
row and we're going to look for the
order id
okay so those two things need to match
in order to fetch the correct product
and let's just hit run
great
i'm just going to increase the row limit
while we are here and now let's use this
fetch product so let's go back in here
and make sure that every time we select
a row
we also execute another function and
that is
fetch
products
so to actually write two we can just use
this javascript function in order to
manually type out the two
uh queries we wanna run so again using
the
two
curly braces i'm just going to add fetch
products and
run
okay and make sure to use the semicolon
here and i'm just going to use one here
so now these two functions these two
queries will run if i click on any one
of these
okay
wonderful
so now that we are getting the products
i want to actually map all the products
that are returned so all the products
for example
in here that have the same order id i
want them to be returned and shown to me
here so let's do it
so let's go into the widgets and i'm
actually going to look for a list
so i'm just going to drag this in here
for now making sure that it fits
i'm just going to drag this down
so here is my
list and the list is just an easier way
to map things onto
a list i guess so that's why we are
using it i'm just gonna move all this
out the way for now and then let's drag
out our list a little bit
okay
so here is our list and now i'm just
going to map out the information onto it
so the information we want to map out is
well it's actually just everything from
the fetch
products
data query so let's just remove all of
this and use our two curly braces and
then i'm going to go into the fetch
products data
and
now
i'm going to use the current items so
let's see what we can use here quantity
i can use item name so let's do
item
and that will map out the item
name just like so we can also use the
quantities about
q t y i believe
q t y with small t y
so we've got one by the cake and five
lollipops and then we can also do the
same for the image so this i believe is
image spell like this but let's just
check i know it's item image so
let's change that
item
image
however as it's two word we're gonna
have to actually just go into
the array and look for anything
with the key of item image
okay making sure to have two curly
braces at
the end
so there we go
this is looking
wonderful
and i believe that's all the data we
really want to show
so
this is looking good so i'm just going
to get rid of this actually we don't
need that anymore and i'm just going to
move this whole list
a little bit higher and then also let's
move the total amount to be below
and the refund amount to be below
2.
great
this
is looking
wonderful
just gonna
make sure that this is all
a little bit more
i liked
okay
so we are now getting our products if i
click on here it should show me the
correct product for this order which is
four chocolates and two candies and the
customer profile is updating too
great
so that was the hard part done believe
it or not the next thing we're going to
do is just link up these information so
let's get our kylie braces up and we're
just going to look in the order data
table so orders
table
and we are going to look for the
stripe purchase id
so actually we need the selected row
don't we selected row and then we're
going to get the stripe purchase id
so there we have it i'm just going to
stretch that out a little bit so it's
more readable
there's the charge do the same for the
address
so perhaps we can make this
smaller actually this doesn't really
need to be as big as it is
so i'm just literally dragging and
dropping things around this could not be
any easier i just want to make sure that
we're getting
all the information we need
on the order information
so just drag that out i'm also going to
drag this out here uh the address now so
once again we know the drill double kali
braces let's look into the orders table
and the selected row we want to get the
address right so address
we can actually just select from this
drop down to see
what we need so delivery address
and then just
spread that out a little bit same for
the status so
let's go into the orders table
let's get the selected row and let's get
the
status
okay so this is looking
good
and finally the date so once again
kylie braces
orders table
selected row
and then we have the
date
and i'm just going to spread that out a
little bit just
like
so
so this is all looking so wonderful we
only have a few things left we need to
hook up the refund functionality with
the stripe api
so
let's do that i'm going to do that right
after actually we um just tidy up our
table a little bit so one cool thing
about this table is that we can actually
edit the
uh columns columns what we want to see
we can also format things so for example
the date
column
so for example for the date column i can
edit this so i can use the
pre-configured date
formats or i can actually write my own
if i want to be super specific if i
don't like any of those so here's some
javascript that i wrote earlier so here
we have the two kylie braces what i'm
doing is getting the current rows date
so the column is called date so we have
to make sure this felt exactly the same
and if it exists
then i'm going to pass it through a
moment i'm going to pass a date through
a moment in its current format
and i'm going to format it to this
format which includes a much more
readable date as you can see here that's
what has been formatted to
and if it doesn't exist then just put an
empty string
wonderful
so that's looking better we can of
course also rename the columns
themselves so if i want order id just to
be a bit more user friendly i could put
order id the delivery dress we can have
as
you know delivery address order amount
status do we need the stripe purchase id
i don't really think we do
need it so i'm just gonna go ahead and
actually make it not visible and i'm
gonna do the same for the customer id as
well
okay
so there we go
the total amount i can actually also
make this much more user-friendly and
just make sure that people know it's in
dollars
so let's go ahead and click here and i'm
just going to add a
dollar sign
to
the end
okay so this is all looking much better
uh let's also add some colors for the
statuses and let's also hide the row
index so where's the row index i don't
want that visible so i'm just gonna
click on the i so these three are not
visible now this is all that's going to
be visible and on the status
i'm just going to instead of putting in
a text color just going to use some
javascript so let's get up our two curly
braces again i'm going to grab the
current
row and i'm going to get the status
column
and if the status equals the string
refunded i want the color to be so if
it's true i want it to be
blue
otherwise
sorry we should be writing this in
javascript
so make sure the js is turned on
otherwise
if current
row
status equals
delivered
delivered
then we want
the color
green
otherwise if current row
status
equals
delayed
then we want it
red
and as a default we're just going to
have
luck so that is some javascript for you
using the tertiary operator and there we
go
and then we can also make this uh
you know we can make it capital letters
if we want so i'm just going to make it
so this is looking good uh we also
actually need to add
be able to add orders
manually so perhaps let's do that bit
next i'm gonna start making my modal
so
let's do it
so on our model let's get up on module
what do we need in here
well i need some inputs
so i'm actually going to have a drop
down so i'm going to use the select drop
down here because we want to select from
a list of already existing customers
so let's put
customer
just like so and at the moment i'm just
going to leave these options in here
because we're just going to do the ui
for now
the next thing we're going to need is a
area to write the address in
so i'm just going to put in an input so
i'm just going to drag in the input
widget
just like so
making sure to move the button down
so there's
the buttons
confirm and
close
and i'm actually just going to copy this
a few times
and then we also need to put in some
labels so i'm just going to drag this
above here
so this label is going to say
address and i don't want it to be bold
so again making sure to keep things
in
line
and we can make this one a little bit
the next one we want is
stripe purchase id so if we want to put
this in manually we need a stripe
purchase id
once again let's not make this bold
and let's also have another select
to choose the
status so again let's pick the
select
widget and just put it under here
and this is going to be for selecting
the status so let's just
put that in here and i think i'm just
going to hard code the statuses because
there's not many so let's go ahead and
do that
so label let's say
order
placed
value order
placed
and then we have
delayed
delivered
and
refunded okay so we're just gonna hard
code these ones i'm i don't mind doing
that delayed
delivered
refunded
okay so these are looking
good
wonderful
we can also have a default value if we
want i think it should be order
placed
okay great
and the next thing we need to do is just
be able to select products from our drop
down so this is actually going to be
another select so i've just copied that
and this one however is going to say
selected products
and now we also need a multi select okay
the multi select is going to allow us to
select multiple products that we want to
order
so let's just make this a little bit
bigger and let's give this the label
uh select
products just like so
and let's write a query for this okay
i'm actually going to write a query for
this as well so that we can get all the
products that we want
so i think this is it now let's just go
ahead and i'm just going to put these
two buttons like so so the close and
confirm button just make sure that the
very end
okay so let's continue with this
so we're selecting our products we're
selecting a status
we also have
the purchase id a place to put the
address and of course the customer name
from a drop down also perhaps let's have
a list so we can see what products we
have selected
so we oh we also need to put in the
total amount as well so this is going to
be a number input
so let's go ahead and get the currency
input right about here
and just
put it like so
so this is going to be for the
order amount so maybe let's make that a
little bit smaller and then let's also
put in some text that says order amount
so here we go and the label will say
order
i'm out and make sure that it's not
bold just to keep everything consistent
i'm just going to make the actual
pop-up model a lot bigger
and then let's also add a list to show
all the products that have been selected
so once again let's find the list widget
just drag and drop it in here
so there
you go
that's looking a lot better
so there is a full order pop-up now
let's get to actually getting the
customers we're gonna have to write a
query for that
so once again back in here we're gonna
make a new
query from our order database
and let's call this fetch customers
or maybe fetch all
users to be a bit more consistent once
again we're going to grab all of this
we're going to put that url in here the
customer
sheet is called customer customers with
an s
so make sure to make that the same
row limit let's put 100 and let's just
run it okay so there we have all our
customers now we're going to use this
query
so let's go back to our zip food
delivery
let's get up our model we're going to
use the query to populate
the
customer drop down so
using the two curly braces i'm going to
fetch all users data okay
so that is all i'm doing
and now i'm just going to map so i'm
going to get each user
that exists
and for each user well what do i want to
do i just want to return the user's
first name
and we also need to give it a value so
we also need to go comma value
and let's just give the value of this to
be the user's
id
okay so that's how it should be looking
now
okay so that's how our array of objects
should be looking now we can also have
the last name so perhaps let's do that
i'm just going to add an empty space and
then add the user
last
name
great so that is what it should look
like at this moment and then we don't
want a default value so let's just leave
that
blank
wonderful
so there we go we've used a query to
fetch all our users so we can select
them in this drop down
the next thing we need to do is uh
figure out how we're going to
do the same for selected products so
once again we're just going to use
exactly the same method that we just did
so we're going to make a new query from
the object database query
let's call this
fetch all
orders or fetch
um product catalog let's call this
product
catalog
so once again we're going to go in here
to get this url
i'm just going to paste it in here like
so and the sheet name well the sheet
name for the product catalog is product
catalog
so let's type in
product catalog exactly like spelts and
making sure the capitals are all capital
and so on uh row limit 100
and click
run
okay so there we go there's our product
catalog which means that now we can go
back here let's get off our module and
let's get the selected products let's
get rid of all this data
and let's go into the fetch product
catalog data
and once again we use the map
javascript function
to map so for each product so for each
item that exists in our array i am going
to
return
a label and a value so the label is
going to be let's go into the product
and get its
item name
and then let's also give it a value
because that's how this needs to look we
need a label and a value and that's
going to be the product id
okay so item has to be spelt with a
capital i actually because that is how
it is spelt in here capital i but id is
small i so just make sure that is the
same so that you can have objects with a
value and a label okay because that is
how we do this and let's not have
default values so let's only have the
option to select certain products
wonderful and now let's map them onto a
list
so to do this i'm actually going to use
this so the multi select one
so i'm going to get the
multi or let's actually rename this
maybe to make this easier i know we
haven't been renaming all of them but i
guess it's just interesting to know that
you can
i'm going to call this product
mo
t select
so that means
that now we're going to use the
product
multi select
and i'm going to get the
selected option values not labels
and map
uh each
thing in my array i'm going to map
it so it returns
what do i need it to return
i just want it to return the fetch
product catalog i'm going to go into the
catalog and find so get the data
and find
the product
that has a matching so id to the product
id so product
id has to equal the id
okay
and now this means that for the image we
can get the current items
item image so let's go into here and get
the item image making sure to spell it
exactly the same as it is here
and now let's test it out let's select
products i'm gonna go lollipop
and there we go so that is updating now
text 13 i guess we want this to be the
item
item
so there
you go and if i select more things so
let's go chocolate
we can see more of them too
so this is looking great i'm so happy
with this
uh and everything is working as it
should we've got all that we need so
let's link this up so that it actually
adds some data to our database
so let's do it i'm going to have to
write some queries for this so once
again i'm going to
go in here and write a new order
database query and this time i'm going
to say add order
and for this to work i'm just going to
once again have to get the same
url however this time i'm going to
insert sheet row so there we go that's
all we're going to do and we're going to
insert this on the orders page
okay and then we're going to make a row
object so this is what we need to do
we're going to get the two back ticks
and then we're just literally going to
look at the orders and then find each of
these column names
so let's perhaps do that now
okay so we're going to have the
order
id making sure to spell exactly the same
so order id the next thing is dates so
perhaps it's easier just to
you know
copy and paste date
the next thing is going to be
delivery address
so let's have the delivery address and
for now i'm just going to keep this
empty
oops this doesn't need to be in two
sorry that's just one like so
the next one is going to be
the total amount
the next one is going to be the status
it's just
like that
then we've got the stripe purchase id
and then we have the customer id so
there
you go
and what kind of data do we want to put
in here
well
i'm going to say that this
id
i'm just going to put this for now and
see what happens the date however is
going to be a lot easier because we're
going to use moment
and then we're just going to do
format
and we're gonna have to make it the same
format that we have currently so year
year month month
day day
making sure that's in strings
the address well that is gonna be the
uh let's actually just save this for now
because we're gonna have to get the
address input so maybe let's call this
address
input let's call this stripe input
i'm going to call this
amount input
because we're going to have to grab all
of these values
let's also have the status select
or status input it doesn't really matter
maybe just everything consistent and the
product multi select that is fine so and
of course the customer so customer
select maybe have
cuss
select so let's hope to remember all
these now
uh okay let's go back to our explorer
and back to writing the ad order
so the delivery address is going to be
the
address
input
text
the total amount well that is going to
be the
amount
input
text
status since again that's going to be
the status input
text and this is going to be the
stripe input
text
and this is going to be the
customer
select
so
which ones were select because we're
going to have to change some of these
this was a
selected
option value
and the status was a selected
option value okay so obviously the
customer id is not being liked why is
that did we not save it
ah we did not save this is not changed
so customer
select and make sure that updates
okay
so this should now all be good selected
option value
this is looking wonderful
um great so actually if i run this it
should add and it has been adding
uh so
great let's actually
delete these for now but we can see the
stuff is working that is good
so we've written a query to add the
order we also need to update it so it
adds a product right so let's go ahead
and do that too
so once again i'm just going to make a
new query
and let's go ahead and add a call it add
product we're going to insert a line
to make sure that this is inside sheet
row let's get the sheet
and let's call this
whatever product is called so products
and once again let's make our object
so this time once again let's just have
a look at what we need to add
well as there could be multiple ones
what we actually need to do is get the
product
list
so these are two curly braces
and the products list
and then get the list
data
and map
each product and i'm also going to get
this index
and i'm just going to return
the id so now we're going to make our
object be id item item image order id so
id
item spell exactly the same
so making sure that the capital is all
the same and all that otherwise you know
it will not work
and we also have the
order id
and the quantity
so
now let's get to picking some out
so for the id what i'm going to do is
actually fetch the product so all the
products and get the length
of my uh column i guess or my table and
just add the index
another item well that's easy it's just
going to be the product
item the capital i because we are just
mapping each one of the product lists
and then we're going to go into the
product again and we're just going to
grab the item image
and now we need the order id so i'm just
going to go this params
id ah of course we need a quantity
because we can have multiple ones in
fact this should not be insert row
this needs to be bulk insert row
okay which means just paste the same
thing again and now let's fix the
quantity part uh well that is just going
to be the products
list
items
index
quantity
input
text
okay
so i don't think we saved product lists
i thought i named my products list
product list but i obviously didn't so
let's go back in here and just make sure
that this list
this list right here so list two
is actually called
product list
wonderful
so
on the product list
i'm just going to add a number input
so let's get the input that is for
numbers
so just drag in the input like so
and make sure the data type is number
and let's
call this
quantity
input
okay
so now each one of these will have a
quantity input as well so we can decide
how many we want
okay so we've written two queries now
let's get to actually making sure that
they both run when we click the confirm
button so let's do it
so for this i'm actually going to make a
utils
uh file so just to make it a little bit
easier for us when there's a lot of
stuff that's going to happen when we do
one thing and all i'm going to do so
let's
do that in
here
i'm going to delete that and i'm going
to write my own function
it's going to be called add order
and it's an async function
and all that's going to happen is i'm
going to
generate an order id so const
order id
equals and this generates
random id
make sure that it's camel case
so this is a function that we will write
in a bit so we're going to do that
we're also going to await and we're
going to run the function add
order
so let's run it
and we'll pass through the id okay so
that's what i was doing when i was using
this params so let's pass through the
order id
we'll do the same for add products
so let's run that it probably should be
products multiple but you know let's
also add the id so the order
id
and then also refresh all the orders
right because we want them to be fresh
and let's reset the widget so i can do
so with reset widget and i'll pass
through the name of the module so it was
called add
modal let's just pass that through
and then let's close the modal too so oh
wait
close
or let's return this actually
return close
module and the model we want to close is
the
add modal
great
and now let's write our function to
generate an id
so that's going to be generate random id
it's going to be a function
that returns
a random so math
random this is a javascript method
2 string
36
sub string
to 9.
maybe let's just make sure to use single
quotes
just make everything a bit more
consistent
and
wonderful
uh we don't actually need these so just
pass it through without the curly braces
so now let's go back to here and let's
use my util so once again i'm just going
to get the model and on click of the
confirm
i'm going to use javascript for this but
i want to go into my utils file
so utils and i want to use do add order
okay so let's try out i'm going to
select
danny address i'm going to just do let's
do test
strike id test id
order amount 30
order
let's say it's delayed and i'm just
going to choose a lollipop and some
chocolate so once again this time i'm
just gonna select the quantity
let's go with one
and in fact maybe let's have a default
of one
so default text one
and click
confirm
and there we have it our order has been
added an order id has been generated we
have added it to our database we've also
added it in the products so there we go
and then we've refetched all of this
data
wonderful
so this is all looking good
okay so we've done that i just want to
show you how to actually delete orders
too so i'm going to show you how to do
that quickly all i'm going to do is
actually go on to my order table and i'm
going to add some new uh columns to here
so let's go ahead and just make one
column and call this deletes
and one other column and let's call this
edit
now for this one i actually want this to
be an icon so let's go ahead and choose
icon button and then let's go ahead and
choose sub delete option
so delete and i'm going to make it red
okay so that's all i'm going to do and
we're going to have to write a you
guessed it a query so let's go back in
here
order database query
this time i'm going to delete a row
we're of course going to grab the
spreadsheet url let's call this delete
order
let's also give this a sheet name so
we're going to be looking in orders as
that's what we are going to delete and
then the row index well once again we
are just going to go into the order
table
and we are going to get the selected row
index this time okay so that is all we
do for the delete order query let's go
back to our app
and now
on the delete button
so just here all i'm gonna do is on
click i'm gonna execute a query and
that's gonna be delete order
okay
so that is all i'm going to do so let's
give it a go let's delete the order i
just made
and then if i refresh
that will be gone oh i've deleted two
why is that
it must have pressed
two perhaps let's try undo that
so for now i'm just gonna copy this
and use this order number
and then let's make this customer one
so now let's refresh
i'm just going to try delete this order
and then refresh
okay so that is working
so of course on success we also need to
fetch
this again so we need to run this again
so on deletes
on success i want to execute a query to
fetch
all the orders again
wonderful
now let's do the edit model so on edit
here we go what do we want well i want
this to be an icon button let's try find
an icon that looks like edit so i'm just
going to type in edit and let's use this
little pen right here and maybe let's
give it the color of blue
i think that's quite nice we don't have
to we can really have any color we
really wish but i think blue is quite
nice
we can also make a secondary button so
that also looks quite cool and on action
we're going to
actually make a pop-up modal show up so
once again let's go into widget this is
going to be the edit pop-up model so
let's find our modal
i'm just going to drop it in here for
now so here is our modal just going to
drop it in like so
okay
and i'm just going to say
edit
order and we're going to show the order
number in here
so it's going to be number
now we get the two curly braces up we're
going to go into the orders
orders
table
and we're going to get the selected
row
and we're going to get the
order
id
okay so that should show up when we
actually select
one of them and let's just make this
maybe a little bit bigger the other
things we're gonna have to edit an order
right so we're gonna populate this with
selected row items
so first things first i'm going to have
just the order date showing up as an
input
so i'm actually going to pick the date
picker for this
and just drag it in like so
so we've got our date picker let's just
put some text next to this
i'm going to say order dates
we're also going to have
we can actually align this i'm going to
align it to the left
just copy and paste that
we're going to have the order date we're
also going to have the address
next we're going to have
the status
and total amount
so i'm just copy pasting new ones
this will say
total
amount
and then we're going to have the stripe
purchase id so these are all things that
we can edit from the order
so this one should say stripe
purchase id
okay maybe we can make this a little bit
smaller if we wish it's totally up
to
us how big we want to make all of these
things
so again like obviously you can style
this as you want i'm just making the
most basic
app
for you in fact perhaps we can even
stretch the modal itself
that's a bit better and now everything
fits
okay so we've got the order date we've
got the address and this i'm going to
actually populate with the date we
currently have so that is again going to
be just today
and let's format this so i want it to
look like so
okay and the address well for this i'm
actually going to have an input
so let's get the text input
i'm going to drag that in here
and this i'm going to say
let's call this edit address
edit
address so if you notice i didn't really
bother naming these as i don't think
they're that important these ones we are
going to have to pick out when we edit
an order in our query which is why i've
done it like so this is going to be edit
date picker so let's
edit
date
picker i'm just going to change it like
so
next we have the status so once again
i'm just going to drag this in here
but before we do that
i'm actually going to put a default
value in here and that is going to be
the existing one so orders
table
and then we're going to get the selected
row
uh delivery address so the
selected row dot delivery address it
should show up and it has
so that will be the default value for
this
once we do actually select one
and the status well the status again
let's gonna go let's give this uh
the name of edit status so edit
status
and the default value is once again
going to be the orders
table
selected
row
dot status
and now the total amount
so you've probably got the hang of this
now let's call this edit
amount
and let's get this the default of order
table
selected
row
total amount
and now the purchase id
we're nearly there i promise
oops
just move that up a tiny little bit
and now we're going to drop for the
purchase id
let's call this
edit
stripe
id
and the default for this is once again
orders
table
selected
row
uh stripe
purchase id
so actually i think that's it let's move
up this button
and let's next write the query right
that we want to call
when we want to update and order so
before we do this i'm just going to
maybe change these colors around a bit
let's make this one orange actually and
let's make this orange whoops
two so let's first link up this uh to
open up the modal so click on the edit
button
so where's the edit button it is here
and the action that we want to do is we
want to
open the modal right so open modal and
the modal we want to open is
modal three it's a shame we didn't call
it but i'm pretty sure that's the
correct modal let's check it out
okay so there we go it is the correct
modal i'm just going to center this
while i'm here so text align center
okay and this button oops why does it
keep doing that i just keep pressing it
by my stick okay just press on it on the
orange bit and i want to make this
button orange but i also want to make it
secondary
great so that is all we need to edit an
order now let's actually
you know let's let's write it up so
this should actually be a select not
a
input
because we want to pick from certain
ones so let's get this select
just put it in here
okay let's not give it a label because i
already have one so let's
shut that label down
so no label
just make it a little bit smaller now
oops
and we actually already have written
these options somewhere
so it was here wasn't it so let's go
back to the other modal
and on the statuses i'm just gonna copy
this
in fact we can actually store this in
the utils file so perhaps let's go ahead
and do that as we are using it in two
places now so in the utils file i'm just
going to export let's call this
order
status
options okay and i'm just going to paste
the whole thing like
that
so now we can use this from the utils
the order status option so let's go back
to our app
and instead
of having so let's click on this model
again
instead of having all of these here i'm
just going to go into the utils
and get the order status options
okay so that is easy and now i can just
use them in the other one so on the edit
let's go ahead and click the edit model
so just click on the select and just
paste
oops
go into the utils once again and get the
order status options
wonderful and let's call this something
this is edit
edit select edit status sorry
and now let's go picking them all out so
we can edit our order
so in fact do we actually have the order
number here add in the order manually
now okay so now let's uh write our new
query using the order database and this
time it's going to say edit
order just like so
and to edit an order well i'm just going
to use update sheet row and i'm going to
copy this once again i'm just going to
paste it in here
and now we're going to make the row
object so the row object is going to be
let's get our object up i'm going to use
the row index
and that is going to be the order tables
selected row index
and then i'm going to use the stripe
pro
chess
id and if it's changed i'm just going to
update it so
let's get the edit
stripe id as we called it
text
next we need the total amount
so once again i'm just going by all of
these column names
so we've got the total amount
and this again is going to be the
edit amount because that's what we
called it when we were making our model
so edit
oops not address edit amount
and this was text so we're getting the
text
and then we need the delivery address
so if it's changeable update and if it
stays the same well then obviously it
will update but it will look exactly the
same so edit address
text
and then we have the date and i'm going
to use moment again so moment
and what i'm going to pass through into
a moment is the edit
date picker
and whatever the selected date is and
then i'm going to format it so
dot
format
and i'm going to make sure that it's the
same as my
database so just change it to be
this format
and then one more and that's the status
and the status is going to be the edit
status
selected
option
value
so this i think is looking good oops we
need to say which sheet we want this on
it's on the orders sheet
okay
great
so i guess let's check it out
so
wonderful let's go here
and let's link it up so on edit
so what if we press the confirm button
what do i want to happen well on click i
want to execute a query and that is to
edit the order and on success i want to
refresh
all the data so re-fetch
fetch
fetch
borders
in fact we actually need to do a few
things so perhaps let's do it like we
did before so in the utils file and
let's write our own
uh i guess
function so update order
it's going to be an async
function just like so
and what do we need to do well we need
to await edit orders so let's run that
so just like this this is how we run it
and then we're also going to fetch the
orders right so await
fetch
orders
run and then we also need to shut the
model so return close modal
and then let's pass through the modal we
want to close it's the edit
middle
great
so that shouldn't be karma commas sorry
it should be semicolons
okay so now let's use this
let's go back in here and i'm just going
to delete all the other ones so
let's get our edit model up
let's click on this button
and i'm actually just going to instead
utils
update order
so let's check it out
um
let's
well there's only one to edit so i'm
going to edit this one and i'm just
going to edit these status
should not really say green oh yes
default value
the status
the default value is going to be of
course the order
tables selected
row
status
oops selected
row
status just wrote that out manually it
wasn't picking up some reason
let's try again so let's just
click on this one edit it
okay so that's picking up and i'm just
going to change it and i'm going to
change it to delivered and confirm and
see if that updates
and
great this is not shutting down oh we
call this modal 3 not edit modal so you
know what
should we just change what this is
called let's just call it modal three
so that is in the utils file
we need to shut
module three
okay
so hopefully you know now how to change
this if you want to but
this is looking good for me so let's
just try edit that again
i'm going to edit it back to delayed
and then confirm
and on success it should shut down the
modal for me now
and it does
wonderful
so this is great we can add new orders
we can edit orders we can delete orders
um i mean i'm really happy with this we
get the order information here so i'm
just clicking on it here and
everything's updating the last piece
that we need to do is to make a refund
so
let's go ahead and do that
so i'm just going to refund this one by
the stripe purchase id
now i'm just going to show you how to do
this by going to the stripe api
okay so we're going to be doing a test
one and i'm going to be showing you how
to do it with the test one of course you
can use real data but i'm going to be
using a test account
and refund is what we want to do
so i'm just going to sign into my
account where i have created some fake
payments already
okay so if i go to payments
these are some fake payments that i have
made i can create a fake payment so
let's just say i make a fake payment for
20
okay and we're gonna uh put in some fake
card information so let's go ahead and
do that now we can just check the fake
cards so payment methods
i'm going to go here and i'm just going
to copy this one i'm just going to put
it in
right here and then just use today so 20
and then cv123
and i think that should be it let's
submit the payment
okay and payment successful so this is a
fake payment all you have to do is
essentially sign up to stripe and then
go to the test payments and create a new
payment so this is the payment that i
have made it is fake
uh this is test data
so this is the payment right here if i
click on this we can find a charge id
so here's the charge id and now i'm
going to use that and put it in here so
that is now my fake payment it's as if i
paid 20 so i know it says uh this here
let's actually just change this to be 20
like so
and now i'm going to essentially
refund
some of this
so
let's
do it let's make a fake refund so using
that in mind that should now be updated
as well so i'm just going to refresh
this there's our stripe purchase id
there's our charge id i want to refund
an amount
okay using this charge id
and for this i'm actually going to write
a function in the utils and it's going
to say
refund order
so refund order
it's going to be an async function
don't forget the comma and what's going
to happen here well i'm going to run the
stripe refund and then i'm going to
update the order amount so that it you
know reflects exactly how much is left
and i'm going to re-fetch the orders so
actually maybe let's do that first let's
write a new query so new query and i'm
going to call this one
uh
update order amount so that is one we
need to write update
order
amount
and this is gonna update the sheet row
we're gonna have to grab
this
and then we need to update the orders
because that is where the uh amount
lives and all we're going to do is we're
just going to update one
thing right we want to just update the
status but for this we also need the row
index because we want to know which row
so which row it is
so the row index is just going to be the
uh
order
table
selected row index
and the status
we want to update is going to be
we're going to have to update it to say
refunded so we can hard code that okay
so that is looking good the next thing
we need to do is write a new query this
time it's going to be a stripe
uh it's going to be we're going to write
our own one
so we're going to create a blank api for
this
and it's going to be a post because
we're going to be posting to the stripe
api and the url for this well we're
going to have to go to
refunds so we were just on this reef
fund
refunds
and
we're gonna have to find
the uri that we need to make this post
request to
so this is it i'm just going to copy
that
okay we're going to use this as a guide
i'm going to copy this
go back in here i'm going to post it to
the uh the v1 refunds
and we're not going to have this we're
actually going to have refund
refunds
the charge id which we're going to pass
through as the order table selected row
and you guessed it stripe purchase id
and i'm also going to pass through the
amount we want to refund so the amount
is going to be
the order
so
order
table
selected row
total
amount
okay so that's where that is going this
is going to be content type application
json and the authorization
authorization that we need to pass
through is going to be this bearer code
so bearer
and let's go ahead and find it in here
this one
and now we just need to get our secret
key
and just paste it in like so
and run it
okay so perhaps it's not picking
anything up but let's check it out let's
see if that works so back in the utils i
am going to to refund my order well we
need to await
and let's rename this api to stripe
refund perhaps
stripe
refund
let's go back in the utils
so await
stripe
refund dot run
and then we're going to return
await fetch
orders
run and of course before that we're also
going to update the orders so await
update order amount
run so a lot going on there
let's go back in here
okay and now when we press this button
i just want to run
execute javascript
function and it's refund order so let's
check it out i'm just going to click
that
oops this should just be v1 refunds
question mark and run
and then we are doing some we're passing
through
obviously stuff that we should not be
passing we just want to pass through the
amount so let's actually fix that
so when we edit
we actually on the edit amount
we want to take off
the dollar
so what i'm going to do is just do
slice
and i'm just gonna take it off like so
okay and of course we already had a
dollar in there
um but that shouldn't happen any more
so let's try fix that now i'm just going
to get rid of this and just make it 20
and
not make this dollar
okay so let's
try this again
okay so if we edit this
and i edit this to say 21
or actually just 20 so confirm
okay so the dollar sign does not get
added and if i try to refund this
so run that
okay
aha it's still
not
liking it it's still trying to add the
dollar so we need to remove that perhaps
we can remove that here slice
zero
nice one
okay
so let's try that now
what we also want to do is disable this
we want to disable this if order
to orders table
selected row is already refunded right
so if the status
equals
refunded
then of course we you know we don't want
to do anything so disable it for that
uh we also need the total amount showing
up here so we can do so easily
order table selected row
total
i'm out
great
and wonderful you will see that has
updated to be refunded so our refund has
happened this is looking so so good
okay so the refund has worked
everything's amazing i'm so happy this
is working
so
great i'm just going to do some final
checking just to make sure everything
works 100
so i'm just going to go ahead and add a
new order so as if we are manually
adding an order of course usually all
our data probably would be just you know
on the database itself but if we ever
need to manually add one this is what
i'm doing now
so here we go
and so i'm just going to go through this
making some fake data making it up
uh of course a random id will be
generated for me
and i'm just gonna go ahead and do this
and
great
i can see that order has been added
however this does say stripe id why is
that
so let's just go here aha perhaps we
need to call this let's just put this as
stripe input i think we tried to change
that and it just didn't work so stripe
input is what i call this
it's already being used is it adds
because we call this stripe input
that's annoying we want this to be
stripe input so let's just call this
stripe title that's why
stripe title so that's why it was taking
the text from here
and we want this to be stripe
input okay so whatever we put in here
will now be updated
great so actually let's edit that it's a
great opportunity for us to check if the
edit
works
so not on this one actually but on this
one
i'm just going to change the stripe id
so i'm just going to make it up for now
and i'm just going to put
ch and then just some random numbers and
click confirm
okay
so hopefully that should work
wonderful so that is now being updated
this is all looking so so good
uh the other thing we need to do is
actually change the name because we just
have the label so this is now easy all
we're going to do is use the fetch user
query and go into the data because only
one item is being returned so we just go
into that item so as it's the first i'm
going to put the zero index and i'm
going to get the first name and then i'm
actually going to just put a space which
is just
two strings with a space and add the
last name too so once again just getting
it from my fetch user query
okay
so this is all looking good
uh and finally why aren't the products
displaying here
let's have a quick look into this
okay so all we're gonna have to do is
this and
there we go okay so everything is now
done of course if you want to rename
this to perhaps add products as it is
more precise just make sure to update
that wherever you use this query okay
otherwise this will of course
break right so where do we use the add
products
let's have a quick look
so add products ah it's actually already
been updated for us so that was really
really great i didn't know that that is
such a uh such a lifesaver really
now before moving on i'm just going to
rename this quickly so just edit the
name right here and there we go i'm just
going to shut these things down as well
as we don't need that
now we are going to connect our project
to our git repository so i'm going to
show you how to do that all we need is
the remote url so head over to your
github account and under repositories
just create a new repository let's call
this zip food delivery app and just go
ahead and create the repository so this
is the url we need so just grab it and
paste it in here and click generate key
now copy the generated key and we're
going to go back to our github and under
settings we're going to go to deploy
keys and then add the diplo key in here
so that our app can essentially
deploy on behalf of us
so paste that in here and let's call
this app key and add the key
so once that is done there is not much
else to do we're just going to connect
and once that has finished we're just
going to actually make a commit so we're
going to commit our project to the
repository we just made
and this means that once this has been
done if we go back to our github
repository so just right here we can
actually view the deployed project
so there we go we are now viewing our
deployed project and our project is
stored on our github profiles
okay
so this is all looking good i hope
you've enjoyed this tutorial i've loved
teaching you it's amazing what we can
build with low code solutions and the
complexity that they can bring
so thanks so much again for coding with
me and i hope to see you again
real soon